the difference between somebody who's  loyal to their wife and somebody who is  not is not the fact that they might get  caught because that happens they're  human you're going to have emotions  right the difference between somebody  who's loyal not is whether they cheat  it's the same thing with patience  honesty it's not do you want to lie it's  do you choose not to despite wanting to  lie it's just like courage it's not the  absence of fear but taking action  despite it and so I think a lot of those  character traits a lot of people it  feels like these amorphous things that  we want to have and take off the shelf  and put inside of ourselves we think  that we need to feel a certain way in  order to be a patient person or be a  kind person or whatever when at least in  my experience it's been you don't feel  that way and you take the action that a  patient or kind or courageous or loyal  or honest person would take despite the  feeling